convert log base 4 of 2 equals one-half
into an exponential
equation so logarithm literally tells
you so if we were to just look at this
part right over here a logarithm is just
saying tell me the exponent that i would
have to raise my base to that would have
to raise 4 2 to get to 2. so tell me the
exponent that i would have to raise it
to to get to 2. and so this equation
written as a logarithmic equation says i
need to raise 4 to the one-half power i
need to raise 4 to the one-half power in
order to get 2. so if i wanted to write
it as an exponential equation i could
literally just say well if i raise 4 and
that's this 4 right over here that's my
base to this exponent to the one-half
power then that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to 2. and
we're done we've written the same
equation as an exponential equation the
value of a logarithm this is this is
saying what do i get if i raise 4 to the
one-half power i get 2 if i raise 4 to
the one-half power this is saying what
do i have what power do i have to raise
4 to to get to 2 and then that is equal
to 1 half so logarithm is saying what
power do i have to raise the base 2 to
get what's inside the logarithm this
says what do i get to when i raise 4 to
the one-half power